for us the highly anticipated follow-up
to a smash hit directorial debut get out
filmmaker Jordan Peele assembled an
a-list ensemble filled with familiar
faces as well as one or two surprises
here's why you feel like you've seen the
cast of us before and where you saw them
first
Lupita Nyong'o is among the most
pedigreed members of the US cast after
modest beginnings as a production
assistant she earned a master's degree
in drama from Yale University and booked
her first major film role shortly after
graduation the young goes work in Steve
McQueen's 12 years of slave netted the
young talent her first Oscar for Best
Supporting Actress making her a breakout
star after big moves like joining the
Star Wars universe
Nyong'o joined the cast of black panther
a marvel juggernaut that crushed
box-office records and won multiple
Oscars as Nakia wakandan spy who was
also a love interest for King to chala
Nyong'o proved she could headline a
blockbuster as well as performing
oppressed II drama making her mark as
one of the most versatile stars around
born in Tobago and raised in upstate New
York
Winston Duke pursued an acting MFA at
Yale University where he met his
classmate and future co-star Lupita
Nyong'o after earning his degree
Duke booked the 7 episode arc as the
violent criminal Dominic on CBS's person
of interest
Duke racked up several TV appearances in
the years since but most people
recognize Duke from his breakout role in
black panther as in baku who leads
wakanda's mountain tribe tim heidecker's
name might not be immediately
recognizable if you don't watch a lot of
late-night cable TV but once you pair
him with his comedy partner Eric
Wareheim it might jog your memory the
duo show Tim and Eric awesome show great
job ran on Adult Swim from 2007 to 2010
while I go up and I look at the stars
through my telescope and I see the
little dipster when I see the big
dipster Heidecker has appeared in a few
films including bridesmaids and marvels
ant-man in the wasp and is typically
cast for the offbeat irreverent sense of
humor that informs nearly all of his
work with where Han and his other
comedic collaborators but his disturbing
turn as an emotionally stunted hipster
in 2012's the comedy showed he's also
right at
and known for her award-winning roles in
some of televisions best prestige dramas
Elisabeth Moss is a veteran of TV and
film who regularly delivers incredible
performances regardless of the medium
loss got her start in television on
Aaron Sorkin's popular drama The West
Wing before going on to appear in major
films like Girl Interrupted her
breakthrough came in Mad Men the AMC
advertising firm drama now hailed as one
of the best series of all time in which
Moss played Peggy Olson and initially
Meeks secretary who ends the series as
an advertising executive with her own
office her first Emmy win came from her
work and who loses The Handmaid's Tale
an adaptation of Margaret Atwood seminal
dystopian novel the Wilson children in
us Zora and Jason are played by Shahadah
right joseph and evan alex respectively
joseph who plays the older sister has
primarily worked on the stage appearing
in school of rock on Broadway and on
television in 2016 hairspray live us
marks her first feature film credit for
which she has already earned praise Alex
the younger sibling has appeared on
television shows like Jim Carrey's
kiddin as well as several episodes of
the youtube series manny and is also
earning his first film credit in US and
a joke got her television starred in
2006 with a recurring role on Everybody
Hates Chris setting the stage for a busy
career to come joke got her first major
television role as a series regular on
the CW's the messengers a show about
five strangers who suddenly find
themselves with supernatural abilities
after appearing on two episodes on
Quantico joke booked a main role in 24
Legacy a sequel to the popular Fox drama
she currently stars in the DC webseries
Titans as Starfire one of the core
members of the super team despite her
young age and relatively small resume
Kara hayward has already made an
impressive entry into our house films at
just fourteen she landed a starring role
and Wes Anderson's whimsical moonrise
kingdom Heyward received plenty of
praise for her breakout performance in
which she held her own against several
oscar-winning actors many of whom were
frequent Anderson collaborators if
you're a big fan of YouTube personality
Miranda
you may also have seen Heyward in season
two of haters back off the Netflix
original comedy series based on the
popular YouTube channel yet another us
cast member with a master's degree from
the Yale School of Drama
Yaya Abdul Mateen burst onto the scene
in 2016 with a huge role on the get-down
a Netflix series about disco and hip hop
in New York in the 1970s the show was
canceled after its first season freeing
up Abdul Mateen to appear in some major
feature films including a role as a
police officer in the film adaptation of
Baywatch after appearing in DC Comics
Aquaman is Black Manta
one of the film's two villains it was
announced that a dual Mateen would
appear in US it looks like Jordan Peele
took a liking to Abdul Matisse the actor
is also set to play the lead in the peel
produced Candyman they're still teens
but identical twins Callie and Noelle
Sheldon have a handful of acting credits
to their name including in one of the
most popular sitcoms of all time as
infants the twins appeared on friends as
Emma Rachel and Ross's baby for a total
of eight episodes at 16 the twins were
cast in US as Gwen and Maggie
Tyler hearing on a long tradition of
twins and horror
perhaps most notably in Stanley
Kubrick's the shiny sari twins you're
kind of creepy it check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]